helps teach kids about the law through
the trial by peers program
that's it what a generous woman that's
the thing that's very busy yeah
great story sherry thank you well at 6
14 as you can see on your screen there
we have hector mejia in the middle of
debauchery more crowds returning to las
vegas
restrictions are loosening up here on st
patrick's day yeah business is hoping to
cash in for st
patrick's day for the first time in two
years now of course this is a huge day
for bars
all right so let's check in with our
lucky charm hector mejia live on fremont
street
with a green pig and a bunch of other
random stuff after good morning to you
oh my goodness isn't this crazy all
right so we're gonna light it up so
we're gonna go ahead and light this up
this is actually
a green colored pig as you can tell
obviously
but this is just part of the offerings
here at project barbecue
isn't this great rob oh yeah this is our
favorite day of the year
we uh we absolutely want invite
everybody down
bring your mask we're going to try to
stay social distance the best we can
we got uh green tacos the green hog
extravaganza
and the cheer squad out there too
welcome back people for after you know
so long well i mean it's been two years
so we uh we're really excited that we
get to do this this year we're trading
gold coins
oh yes absolutely all day long so this
is crazy what's the up process and
what does it take to put this together
and are you guys selling this today
just one or many no we have many we're
limited so get your orders in
i already have one what's that we
already have one order in yeah we have
one order since this morning so
we gotta we got a couple more to go and
uh just give us a call and
we'll place your order in time so we've
seen green colored rivers we've seen
green beer
green tacos how'd you come up with the
idea with a green pig
you know we've been down here four years
and meet a lot of people
this little irishman came up and uh he
told us hey this is what you should do
and gave us a recipe and uh
man did it work did it work all right so
we asked earlier
what does this pig taste but for you how
would you describe it actually
we came up with a name this is little
ricky yeah little ricky's this one
you'll get to name your pig and uh we
can definitely uh post whatever you guys
come up with
still tastes like chicken or for you
more like shrimp or what no no no i'm a
pork fan so it tastes
exactly like it should juicy that's
great a
juicy green colored cake with uh some
candles on it
oh this is our twist to bottle service
you know everybody likes to be seen and
get your pictures taken so
we'll bring it out we blow horns
whistles got our cheers staffed right
behind us and
absolutely will you be seen out on the
street
and i really can't sense that you guys
are excited oh yeah this is this is
great
uh two years in the in the making here
uh one more thing you guys also have
green tacos
oh yeah so uh chef rex uh my partner
will be uh
showing you guys a little later how to
make the green tacos and uh
it's a green tortilla oh green tortilla
yes
and we got a spin on that we're gonna uh
probably raffle some things off for
every order we'll give a raffle ticket
and
give you guys something by the end of
the day awesome thank you so much for
having us all right you guys so look at
this just
look at it we'll try not to look at it
directly
in the face we actually covered the
eyeballs with these uh coins
may i yeah oh pardon me so uh yeah so we
have uh these
whoops but you can just see just look at
them it just looks
delicious i mean yum yum yum yum yum
right oh yeah
i mean this is this is what people like
to do come out enjoy
celebrate st patrick's day out here on
fremont in front of circa
across from golden gate so awesome thank
you very much all right well reporting
live hector mejia
back to you guys hector do not look at
him in the face
hector is setting stuff on fire
little rookie
we've heard of irish stout and little
ricky is an irish
snout oh my god he was wearing the same
hat i've got on did you notice the
results oh i don't see your hat there
look at you sherry
did you i'm wearing a t-shirt later it
says kiss me i'm irish come on
make sense i've got my antennae on so
we're
we're good to go as we are tune in your
shamrocks there i think you can get your
favorite radio station
hbo yeah wow all right so we'll check in
with hector a little bit later on
as before things go completely off the
rails here happy st patrick's day by the
way
to you and yours on a on a lucky
wednesday morning sherry's a beautiful
almost sunrise we are totally lucky i
haven't found the leprechaun yet but
i've certainly found clear skies and
light winds hopefully that works for
everybody
i think you're going to love your
wednesday your st patrick's day
whether you're out celebrating or just
enjoying the sunshine
we've got lots of 40s out there this
morning seven hills